with a story here from timcast.com
zelenski warns of World War III if China
allies with Russia I do see an
opportunity for China to make a
pragmatic assessment of what is
happening here I wanna I wanna I wanna
bring this up because for those are just
tuning in or just jump into the segment
we are talking about religion cultural
Decay societal decay Joe Biden the
president of the United States
went on a surprise visit to Ukraine with
a 500 million dollar gift
you know you could use 500 million
dollars people in Ohio people in Ohio
people in Flint Michigan project Veritas
care in America I say yes the project
Veritas but you know in all seriousness
um Pittsburgh's got a pipe
problems sprinkle some iron dust into
the rivers in East Palestine and then
put a magnet in there because what
happens is the oil coagulates around the
iron particles and then you can use a
magnet to get the oil out so let's hear
Greta thundberg's going to just kidding
go ahead oh yeah
it's this simple yeah we're being warned
of world war three
Russia we're being told the world is on
the brink of Destruction
why would there be World War III if
China allies with Russia oh what he's
actually saying is because the U.S will
blindly and unapologetically give
Ukraine all the support that it ever
wants if China Russia team up yes the
U.S will fall in line behind zielinski
and go into an international conflict
between two superpowers or two world
powers Jimmy Dore was saying that how
zelinski is really falling in line
behind the War Machine and if he says no
we're gonna have peace that they'll just
kill him I I I I think so I'm just I see
this
world war three what if the US just says
not we're not interested in war not over
Ukraine what if Russia and China team up
and they say we're now going to take you
crying in the US went
you were not Ukraine have a nice day
what he's saying is the U.S will do what
Ukraine wants
well especially since we've already
poisoned poised all of our citizens to
be obsessed with Ukraine do you remember
all the flags everywhere all the time
like we made this an issue that
apparently are especially
liberal-leaning voters are going to die
on right so if Biden backs out if he
says oh actually I'm going to cut off
funds then his base will turn on him and
be like how could you abandon them I
wish that were true I think they'll
actually just
oh great yeah okay then I I think
they're that compliant I think I I think
Joe Biden and say this is our new
foreign policy fart noises in the armpit
and there and that'll be the new that'll
be their new Avatar on Twitter tomorrow
I've got a a pair of Vans shoes they're
blue with like a yellow stripe on it and
I've had people being West Virginia
colors or the Ukraine colors exactly and
I've had people be like oh you know blue
I'm like oh come on man just choose West
Virginia forever West Virginia shoes
we'll just call them West Virginia shoes
this issue that weird with Ukraine is my
last nerve
and
and this is hard for me to say as a kid
who's a child of the of the 80s who grew
up in the we're America 80s who
wore Alex P Keaton monogrammed sweater
vests okay and and got up in the middle
of the night to cheer Reagan bombing
Gaddafi back to the Neolithic period
this is hard for me to say okay
you're taking my my high school age son
to fight and die in Ukraine literally
Over My Dead Body I'm never allowing
that I'm never letting you take him to
die for your Habsburg Dynasty World War
One needless 20 million pile of deaths
replay over your Elites pissing contest
not happening I don't care what the
threat is I don't care what the penalty
is and if you think you're drafting my
daughters get the camps ready because
you're gonna need them never happening
this is a this is this is an example if
history doesn't just repeat it Rhymes
this is a hat these are but these are a
bunch of Elites a little cabal that are
all throw Putin all of them all in
together this is a Habsburg Dynasty
pissing contest over a strip of land
most people can't find don't care about
has no strategic value to anybody within
the sound of my voice unless they're
involved in investing money with Hunter
Biden this thing is such a Croc it's so
fake it's so phony it's one of the most
simplistic disgusting stories I've ever
seen it's one of the most cynical
stories I've ever seen it's Wag the Dog
but dumber and and and and this this to
me is the final straw of just absolute
civil obedience we're never fighting
your damn War hell no I think it's such
pageantry I think you're totally right
it's all fake I mean the fact that
zelinski can come to our Congress and
not manage to put on a suit Joe Biden
goes to see him wearing a suit like he's
playing a character it's so bizarre he's
the only world leader on the brink of
War apparently or in the middle of War
who has to be in I guess camo or
whatever to convey to these people that
yes in fact we are fighting so much so
that he has time to do a Vogue cover
shoot with his wife I mean it's just
bizarre YouTube he's got time for you
too got time for you too he's got time
to make major public appearances around
the world via VIA Zoom I guess he's not
he can't leave his country but it's all
for show he has to continuously say this
is so drastic of course Lindsey Graham
is saying oh Mitch McConnell uh with his
Ukrainian tie the most important air
show in the country
as you're crying okay uh Lindsey
grahamnisty uh uh well I don't care
about provoking Putin of course you
don't because you don't have any sons
you made that lifestyle choice you don't
have any sons so nobody with your DNA
Lindsay's going out there on those
battlefields to freaking die for
somebody's trust fund or grift fund
it'll be our sons those of us who do
have uh children they're the ones that
go out there won't be Hunter Biden I
mean he's tried to kill himself with
enough crack we all know that but it
won't be him doing it it won't be their
son's dying it'll be ours hell to the no
never happening shove it up your ass
we're never doing this but I think you
need more Americans saying stuff like
that I remember when my brother uh he
was a marine he deployed to Afghanistan
did any of us think we should be there
it was crazy and yet we have we have
been sending people to Wars because
we're we say they're supposed to be
there for a long time I hope that
Ukraine is a wake-up call right that
these are people who should not be going
that we're sending anyways for pointless
things but I just don't know that it
will be I hope it is I like that you are
likening it to the Habsburg Dynasty
which is like a family that was obsessed
with keeping the Germans and I don't
know the actually the literal history of
the Habsburg family they were all
married they were all related was that
where they had like the weird jaws and
like the deformities they were like east
of Germany were they like
Austria-Hungary and Hungary it was many
after a certain point it was just a lot
of people and they wanted in breeding
business and they were trying to control
The Descent within Europe yes yep yep
maintains Germany so they like that the
Germans and the Russians are fighting
because if the Germans had won World War
One
what would have been different what was
World War nothing thought about not
nothing it was a pissing contest of
Elites my group of my wing of the
Habsburg Dynasty will rule over yours
wasn't it and that'll cost 20 million
lives well the only thing that came that
was the only good thing we did in World
War one is perfected freaking
distribution of mustard gas we didn't do
anything else
they're all related all the habsburgs by
the time we got to 19 by the time we got
to 1914 they're all related this
intermarrying Within These Empires had
gone on for centuries they're all
related by the time we get there and so
it's just literally a it's literally a
playground across this draw Line in the
Sand cross this line your ass is mine
that's what we used to say when I was a
kid all right so they they the the
Archduke Ferdinand son gets kill or
nephew was it I think can't remember
gets gets assassinated they cross the
line now the other alliances come in
across the line before you know it now
uh The Guns of August have fired 20
million people died from nothing all we
did in World War one was lay waste to
Germany to give birth to the Third Reich
and the worst regime that's probably
ever existed in the history of humanity
was it like just an arms development
research program the war under the guise
of a war like we want to see how our
tanks fight against our taxes as a kid
born to a 15 year old mommy and I don't
know what it's like to have so much of
that inherent privilege that after a
while you're just like I gotta fire off
some of these rounds because I can't
just throw them away I don't know the
answer to your question I mean my mom I
was on food stamps as a kid so I don't
know the answer to that question all I
know is there is no if if you look at
traditional Christian just War Theory
this is not fighting and dying for
Ukraine morally is not a just War period
I agree with that sentiment well at
least from this perspective it doesn't
look like it I I think that he wants
Sebastopol the the trade port and that
he wants East 105 that freeway going
down if we act like he's going
to want East 97 and East 105 everything
east of the denipro river but I mean I
don't see why Armistice isn't the focus
I'm not I am no fan of Vladimir Putin I
can't tell you how many times Russia
Today tried to book me on their shows
and I like never returned their calls
that all being said
Vladimir Putin didn't try to turn me
into an experiment for Pfizer and
moderna for the last two years right
Vladimir Putin didn't say by the way if
you did not consent to being a member of
said experience experiment you can't
work like little like Mark of the Beast
you can't buy or sell stuff because how
the hell you get a buyer sell anything
you have a job all right so you can't
work I didn't say hey your family
business is not essential that that
business that your family's had for 100
years that Family Farm it's not
essential anymore it's got to go we
don't even need to be so specific to be
completely honest if Vladimir Putin's
under a doorstep the Soviet Union
doesn't exist it collapsed and this is a
border dispute with Russia and Ukraine
that for some reason the U.S thinks it's
worth going to World War III over so I
agree they're sentiment we've got I
agree with that too the calls if you
look at our biggest problems I often say
to my audience on the blaze or my
Twitter feed the calls are coming from
inside the house all right the calls are
coming from inside the house we have
we've got we've got 90 you want to go to
war with China how about maybe taking
back control of your medical supply that
you gave them eighty percent of the
manufacturing we can't go to work do
they're actually some of the they've
actually they actually make some of our
own weapon systems we're gonna award the
country that that makes all of our uh
all of our 80
and even some of our high-tech weapon
systems that most of our Elites want to
be like Anyway the calls are coming from
inside the house the battle is here I've
often uh we've talked about this quite a
bit what would happen if China declared
war on the US right now if they said we
are officially Warring States back the F
off
vitamin C antibiotics
skateboards would be gone people have no
idea how much of the standard products
we get are made in China and shipped
here
if China said we're at War and cut off
trade
what half of our box stores would be
empty you'd be like wait where I can't
get medicine anymore no no it's actually
made in China not crazy they'd be just
as screwed so I don't think it doesn't
really make sense just just as screwed
I'm not so convinced oh yeah good point
the amount of Farmland they own and they
could just go Stalingrad on us and just
burn the Farmland to cut off our supply
chain I mean we're in this position
because the great experiment of of
utopian progressivism globalism didn't
work and the reason it didn't work is it
ignores the basics of human nature and
this says this is how crazy the times
have gone when I got into this business
15 years ago Bill Maher was was doing
documentaries like religious religion
religious yeah thank you and I mean I
was doing whole shows debating him on
that now now I do shows where I play
clips of Bill Maher and affirmatively
quote again all right even though I'm
not sure he's changed any of his views
and I know I sure as hell haven't
changed any of mine but at least at
least the old culture War I liked the
old culture War the old culture War
where people like me and people like Mar
debated we we both agreed first of all
that individuals have some agency and
human beings have some rights of
conscience
and the debates that people like me and
people like Mar were having is what's
the limit on that right of conscience
right he basically is by his own
admission a libertine he basically made
the McKee Marquis de sad argument if I'm
not hurting anybody else nobody else's
problem you know do what that will that
is the whole of the law that was
essentially his argument okay people
like me made the argument well there's a
little bit more to it because the one
that gave us our agency and the one they
gave us that uh conscience has a few
rights uh of of of limiting it that we
need to listen to for our own good and
that was the argument that we had is is
did people like me go too far people
like him go too far somewhere in the
middle a reasonable Society could emerge
the new argument now is you have no
individual agency at all you have no
rights of conscience at all and so this
is why without changing our positions on
literally anything this is why Bill
Maher and Steve days are saying a lot of
the same things right now because we are
both recognizing that old argument about
agency and conscience is out the window
we're actually having an argument
whether we have any agency or conscience
whatsoever are we totally Wards of the
state from the moment we breathe but
also I think Bill Maher started finally
paying attention to the news I think he
knew more than he was letting on for a
while and he just didn't want to say
anything because his audience is it's
liberals but he got to that point where
he's saying this stuff and he's like I
just can't anymore the issue and this is
exemplified by the Prager uh episode
where Prager said they're putting
tampons in men's room and the men's room
and Bill Maher laughed and the audience
laughed and everyone said no that's not
true and then bill was like that's for
their girlfriends what are you talking
about and Prager was completely correct
so I I think I think uh has has Bill
Maher apologized for that I think he may
have addressed it I think I've talked
about it recently I can't remember but
what what we've been watching for a
decade Bill Maher has only started
paying attention to in the past couple
of years so I wonder if the issue is
simply all of those things you were
worried about 10 years ago in the old
culture War bill just didn't read
so he didn't know what he was talking
about did he really think that tampons
were in men's bathrooms to bring to
their girlfriends he when when Dennis
Prager brought up that he Dennis Prager
said if you claim a man can menstruate
you're a liar and everyone laughs and he
goes that's what they're starting to
claim and who and Bill's like who who's
saying it's like it's in the maintenance
all over the news Google it just Google
search it you'll see it and then they
all start laughing he's like they're
putting tampons in the men's room and
then bill goes that's for their
girlfriends come on no one's saying this
and they're all just laughing at him and
uh of course Prager was completely
correct but Bill Maher he's how old is
he and he's sick he's in his 60s he's
not paying attention to what's going on
he has no idea what's going on at these
universities he doesn't read the news
but he is now that's the wonderful and
yeah well maybe when his publicist came
to him and said hey they're calling you
a Nazi he was like what me they're like
yeah because you said these things like
what oh I bet he went because in early
2000s his show Politically Incorrect was
off the chain awesome and then it got
kick he got kicked off TV because he was
too hot for TV telling the truth about
the war machine he said what he said the
guys that hijacked the planes were
probably not cowards because that was a
brave thing to do to throw your life
away for something you believe in was
saying no you can't say that yeah well
then what happens is you go into
hibernation where it's like I I'm I just
got to pretend like everything's fine no
no goodbye and then finally you can't
take it anymore you gotta speak up he he
got older he's not consuming the the
up-to-date information on things like
I'm not gonna be able to come here and
tell about the latest Tick Tock Trend I
don't know and in 10 years when all of
these young people who have built up big
followings on Tick Tock are not talking
politics I'm not going to see what
they're saying of course me
understanding that issue I try to have a
better connection to the the generations
concerns and the political Arena of
which right now as Millennials I'm
entering I'm mentoring the entering
mentoring the end of my third I'll be 37
and about two uh two weeks 37. so uh for
younger people what do we do well we've
we got you know you're you're young ish
I guess a token female young person
there you go we're bringing young people
and we uh we where we try to pay
attention what younger people are
talking about but there's a lot less
younger people care about politics and
that's the way it tends to be when Bill
Maher turns 60 and Millennials are now
in their 30s inheriting these systems
and saying raising kids of their own
raising kids having a perspective Beyond
just their own selfishness and see where
schools are doing seeing what they're
teaching their kids
they're talking about it you get loud
and Counting you get that fight and Bill
Maher in his 60s doesn't pay attention
to these mediums has no idea what's
going on and I'd be willing to bet the
only reason he became he came to the
position where he is now calling it out
is because he kept getting notes from
his publicist saying you're a Nazi today
you're a white supremacist tomorrow and
Bill was probably like what is this what
are you what are they complaining about
why am I getting negative press from all
of these people then he gets half
introduced to what everyone else is
talking about now he's like this is
crazy people are yelling at me for this
stuff if Bill Maher actually paid
attention to a show like this or to the
commentary we've had for the past
several years or even like the Lotus
Eaters podcast with Carl Benjamin for a
decade he'd be well versed on the modern
culture wars but it's not just that he
doesn't pay attention it's that I think
this is true for most most uh
demographics Generations they care about
their peers I don't pay attention to
what gen X's are paying attention to
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time